this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by liquid iv
and keeps more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com and
i want to say thank you to every one of
you
for subscribing for the messages the
emails all of it this community is
growing
and i absolutely love your [ __ ] medal
i love it i love that you all are over
here just laughing at the [ __ ] thrown at
us it's a good
time uh it's the best therapy and i'm so
glad you're on board
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel and uh
you'll get audio every monday video on
tuesdays and if you gotta have more
episodes subscribe to the patreon
uh it's five bucks a month if you sign
up for your year you get over a month of
free episodes and that community
is just man the [ __ ] stories that are
coming out of that show you
just go look go look at the promos on my
ig it's nuts
cast a line out to all y'all and y'all
haven't let me down
if you or someone you know has that
story it has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcastgmail.com hopefully
with to do an episode with you you do
not need to be a patreon member
uh so submit it hopefully with the
chance to do an episode together now you
know we record here at the santa monica
music center
um and working with this uh with
our guests making me laugh working with
these kids right now on outreach through
the arts uh uh of
non-at-risk kids with the santa monica
police department
and uh you know we're teaching them how
to podcast editing cameras everything
that goes into bringing a show like this
out there and i gotta tell you they're
loving it we're loving it so i'll keep
you updated on that
we had the chief of police santa monica
police in here
uh she was in here black lady by the way
that ladies yeah sutton she's over there
making history so she was in here
they're excited about the program i'm
excited about it just something
i want to tell you all about how many of
these kids do you think are going to
flip it into an only fans
we haven't taught them about that yet
yeah they'll figure out three classes
so real quick uh you know what we do
here we highlight the low lights
uh these are the stories you're
highlighting a low life
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and as you can see ladies
and gentlemen our guest this week
russell peters y'all hey look at that i
got the clap from you thank you for
being here brother
thanks ryan it's good what you're doing
to these kids i'm for these kids
thank you well sir yeah you got to say
the words are very important
doing for and doing two are very
different very different
yeah doing four is what you're doing and
doing two is what the catholic church
does
that's right thank you thank you why i
left the catholic church
me too uh before we get into uh
your life your stories please promote
everything and anything you have a new
podcast
new podcast culturally cancelled on
iheartradio uh just a hang basically hey
we do it in my backyard we sit around we
drink we smoke cigars we talk [ __ ]
and it's uh you know we've had all kinds
of different i like to put three people
on at a time just to
[ __ ] up the energy in the room you know
what i mean like so it's like
so you know who did i have i think i had
uh
i had kangal kid from utfo okay
smooth b from nice and smooth uh lord
finesse and myself was like i think the
very first one we did
we just sat around talked about hip-hop
and then uh so you
you are an old hip-hop oh yeah you go
way deep on that then we had one with
uh cedric the entertainer and uh oh had
sean porter
showtime sean porter on with me on that
one and then sean's dad kenny porter was
there and i think reuben paul dropped in
it was just
it's just loose you know what i mean
yeah hang like it's really kind of like
if you were to wonder what happens in my
backyard and we're sitting around
talking that's basically we're recording
it now
all right and what's where is it again i
heart i heart radio all right
culturally canceled with russell peters
any uh
any live performance dates at this point
right now yeah i don't want to brag guys
but i got a bunch of dates they're on my
website russellpeters.com all right um
i don't know when this is gonna air so
uh in a couple weeks april's gonna get
cancelled i know that
because uh you want to wait till after
yeah no well april the uh dates are
getting canceled i got to do but i got
to do something in canada
so but after that revisit
um well again thank you for being here i
told you uh what we do over here at the
end by the way i forgot to tell you
you're a first-time guest after we talk
about what we're gonna talk about i'm
gonna ask you what advice you would give
your 16 year old self all right
yeah so let's start tell me give me your
yours
is a life story mine's a life story i
got a lot of years on me
uh what do you want to start with where
do you want to start well you're born
toronto born in toronto in 1970
um and are you an only child no i have
an older brother he's six years older
than me
so from the age and my parents we were
latchkey kids so
from you know from the time i i was born
my mom and dad both worked and they both
they weren't professionals you know what
i mean i heard somebody the other day
use latchkey and they were like yeah my
mom would pick me up i'm like whoa
what yeah ain't no pick up you get your
[ __ ] self home with your own key yeah
you go in the house
if you got picked up you know i was a
latchkey kid nobody was picking up
somebody matter of fact they rode right
the [ __ ] by while we were walking home
yeah yeah
my brother my brother and i would take
the bus i was four he was 10.
damn we we would get on the bus together
public transit not not um
can you imagine if somebody put their
four-year-old on a public
uh bus oh my god [ __ ] you they'd
you'd lose your kids you would you would
lose your kids
yeah so it's a weird world we're living
in now and i don't remember anything
happening to kids back then
i don't remember that many close calls
with you or your brother no nobody
wanted a brown kid we're low uh
we're low on the totem pole you'll be
stuck with them
is that your kid that's my pet monkey it
just throws me a banana
[ __ ] so yeah you know for age of four
my brother and i would take that he
would take me to school we went
we're in the same school back then and
then we would stop on the way home and
get a jumbo burger it was called jumbo
burgers would stop there and then we'd
have to walk because
it was just far enough from the house
where a bus waiting for the bus wouldn't
make sense
right and uh but still far enough we're
like [ __ ] i gotta do this walk now
that's a lot on a 10 year old too i'm a
lot of responsible
my brother's always been very
responsible so that was good that worked
out well because if it was me
and him we would have been [ __ ] and
did that did you grow closer because of
it or did you he's my manager now
still so you're still good to go we're
still good yeah no [ __ ] matter of fact
we facetimed each other today me him and
my mom's staying in my house right now
so that's nice
it was nice little three of us on
facetime that's good so you
you grow up like that now what what sort
of student are you
terrible i'm a terrible student so we
moved from toronto okay
in 1974 or five 74 75 we moved
from toronto to brampton which is the 20
minutes outside of the city
and uh it's a working-class blue-collar
town
and uh what did your parents do my dad
worked in a chicken
factory when we moved to brampton
otherwise he worked in a a
slaughterhouse in toronto
so no see was killing some it was b he
worked in a beef slaughter house
and he was a meat inspector and then so
then he
we moved to brampton where my dad worked
at the chicken plant
we did the same [ __ ] with chickens and
my mom worked
uh my mom ended up working at kmart
y'all had kmart in canada yeah i don't
know i didn't know they were
international
yeah they're everywhere yeah the only
thing that's not international is
[ __ ] ihop
ironically i mean [ __ ] false ass
advertising
oh [ __ ] and what's it like growing up in
a town like that were you guys
middle class lower middle class working
class yeah yeah working class
like there was no extras you had what
you needed that was you didn't have no
extras well said yes you know what i
mean it was like yeah i had shoes i
might have been falling apart but you
had [ __ ] shoes
and if they did fall apart then you
would get new shoes you know
uh and so this neighborhood we grew uh
we moved to was a little townhouse
complex
and very racist very very very
very white racist well in canada in the
70s there was very a lot of racism
towards indian people
um black people getting it but not
anywhere near what we were getting
really like we were below everything
because we were easy targets we're small
we're you know they have funny accents
i didn't have one obviously but and i
couldn't figure out what the [ __ ] was
happening
they would call us pakis okay um
and this is like you this is the first
this is what you're seeing at four five
six years old yeah
and i don't understand what's happening
right i'm four and a half five years old
i'm like is your brother fighting or
anything
well my brother my brother's kind of
figure it out he's like he's 11 now he's
like i don't know the [ __ ] going on
either
so um we moved to this townhouse complex
and
literally i am you know i'm a
five-year-old kid i go to the park i
don't know i take a piss in the park you
know what i mean i
i peed on this they'll do that yeah and
they were like [ __ ] fun with you you
[ __ ] packy and there's grown people
talking to me like this oh really these
are adults these are adults doing this
these aren't kids these are adults
a little five-year-old they don't give a
sh i was a cute [ __ ] kid too to be
honest
but and i but i didn't know it was cute
because so many people
[ __ ] on you for so long you don't know
anything ain't good about yourself at
that point
so i i dealt with a lot of that and as
you got older it got worse
like the you know because it because you
you kind of got beaten down at a young
age your brain goes
oh you have no you have no recourse in
this you're just gonna have to take this
you know what i mean so can i ask you a
question because obviously
i'm i've never had uh consistent
racism uh you know because used against
because
i'm white and my privilege um but
you know do you get to a point and i
don't want to say
because that you get used to it but you
said you accept you accepted it you
actually were like
i you weren't gonna fight back or no you
knew that no matter what you did it
didn't matter no if you fought back you
were going to get beat up worse
because you were getting beat up for no
reason like you would go to the park
eventually after having a good time with
the other kids
somebody would either spit on you or
punch you in the head [ __ ]
right when we moved into the townhouse
complex i'm riding my bicycle
in the neighborhood and i get down the
street to the stop sign there's an older
white man
watering his lawn i'm a five-year-old
kid i stop at the stop sign i don't know
why because when you're
a kid on a bike you want to pretend
you're driving a car so you see a stop
sign you stop
and uh this white man's watering his
lawn i go hi and he sprays me with his
hose gets [ __ ] out of here packy
damn yeah grown man
cut two that was 1975. cut to 1984.
sorry your first sort of it was not my
first
he was but he was definitely like one
that's number one that's not a kid
yeah that was that was the one where i
was like oh that [ __ ] uh-huh
okay i see who you are anyway cut to
like ten years later
um i don't live in that townhouse i'm
just getting all in your yard later
[ __ ] oh yeah it's even better
so i ten years later my friends lived in
the in the buildings behind
there was across the street was like
these apartment buildings so my
my friends still lived there so and we
had moved so but you still had to walk
through my old townhouse to get to my
where i had moved to so i'm walking home
one night from my friend's place me and
him he's walking back
with me and uh that guy's house was on
the corner
and i was walking by i go look at that
[ __ ] sitting in his living room
and he had a big window i picked up a
brick i threw that [ __ ] right through
his [ __ ] window
and that's funny because i saw his wife
maybe uh
love looks good though yeah
yeah damn you threw a brick man [ __ ]
that guy
they didn't call the police or anything
like that i don't know what they did we
were gone
done whatever they wanted to do but uh i
was gone you saw his wife
i saw his wife um in the mall and that i
grew up like in the hometown that i grew
up in
maybe i saw him maybe like i want to say
like 14 years ago
and i was like i was with my mom and i
go oh look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
still here
my mom was russell stop that i go no you
know who her [ __ ] dirty husband was
i love that you hold that grudge oh yeah
cause i'm a grown he was a grown-ass
monk
yeah yeah god damn
and so when at what age do you start to
develop
the comedy muscle that is probably why i
think
i think at that age is when i started
doing it because i was like
i think i've always been innately a
happy person it's like it's something
you
you're born with either you are you're
not yeah and uh you know people can try
and [ __ ] with it
and they can and they do and they do but
you can't take it away
you can you know stifle it a little bit
but that's about it but i used to use
comedy to get out of situations
and you know and then from from the age
of four all the kids i associated with
were black kids
because they were the ones not doing
anything to me
they were the ones were literally equals
we were just
it wasn't even like oh he's black let me
talk to him just like didn't occur to me
i was like
hey these guys don't bully me i'm gonna
go hang out with them
and then we would end up doing dumb [ __ ]
together and
well as i'm guessing i mean skin color
wasn't a thing for you you knew it was
the way you were being treated but for
you you didn't give a [ __ ] who anyone
looked like
right it didn't i didn't it didn't occur
to me right because
but it's funny because i remember i
didn't know what a [ __ ] packy was
when i would hear it the [ __ ]
back he's coming like and and i would
run with them like i'd run into the
party like [ __ ] packing and they
don't run and i'd and i'd run too
and they think i'm chasing them and i'm
like i don't want the [ __ ] packing to
get me either
i thought i thought it was like a ghost
and i came over my mom goes we're not
from pakistan we're from india
tell them that i go i'm not they don't
give up i'm like i'm not gonna correct
them
that's not gonna be the win let me
correct your racism so you can do it
properly you're gonna insult me do it
properly
be accurate please be accurate with your
racism
yeah that's and that's probably why
that's probably why i do this
the comedy that i do because i i'm when
i do talk about
specific races or cultures or
nationalities
i'm very specific with it and i think
that comes from
people doing broad stroke racism on me i
was like listen i want this to be right
yeah well i'm watching you out here with
lana with knowing everything she's
talking about these
these countries dialects languages yeah
okay so do you remember having
conversations other than that with your
mom and dad about this
you know maybe their experiences of
racism well my identity
isn't new no see my mom's very
fair-skinned
she could pass she's not much darker
than you
if she is indian yeah she's from india
born and raised not much darker than not
much darker she just looks like me but
but fair skin i'll show you a picture
just to get an idea um
i just posted it on my instagram too as
a matter of fact let's go to that
picture let's let's go to the tape kids
um okay so
that's mom and that's her with a tan oh
yeah okay right uh-huh it just looks
like me if you really look at it
lodge
i had to zoom in it's on instagram so
you gotta use two fingers
right use two fingers use two fingers on
my mind
there you go i got two fingers on your
mom
[Laughter]
and then my dad was a little bit darker
you know
yeah for sure so anyway um
yeah my dad dealt with that [ __ ] too so
but when so when he moved to canada my
dad my dad was an english major so he
always wanted to be a writer
is what what took them to canada an
airplane um
they uh they wanted to get out of india
because the type of indian we are we're
anglo indians we're mixed
like and we're mixed with british and
the and anglo indians
um marriages educate us anglo indians
used to marry anglo-indians
because they were the same mix so
there's some very famous angles and the
mix is british india british and indian
the father had to have been british the
mother had to be in india okay and if
the mother was
uh british and the father was indian
that's a eurasian
oh okay i didn't know that yeah but
eurasians didn't have much
um of the cultural [ __ ] happened
anglo-indians
were born and raised in india but their
first language is english
and all of their cultural things are
british
so growing up when i'd go to india
everybody spoke english because all my
family spoke english
and at four o'clock it was tea time okay
and they would want snacks like scones
and [ __ ] like that you know what i mean
um so that's what i knew and we did
indian food obviously
because that's the food around and then
they learn whatever language they need
to learn
for where they live so my mom grew up in
calcutta she learned how to speak
bengali
because that's where she was born and
raised but for english was still her
first language
my dad was born and raised well now
raised he was born in bombay
and so he learned how to speak the
language there which is marathi
and he spoke that he knew how to speak
he did he knew how to speak it and they
both knew how to speak hindi which is
the national language
but english was their first language and
even when they would speak the other
languages they still weren't that good
at it but they could communicate yeah
they could communicate they could
understand it you speak more than one
language
no i i fake it through every language
but i can make you think i can speak
your [ __ ] language
like i know enough of each language
where i make you go
i don't think we should speak about it
he's going to figure it out
he's going to figure this out that's all
i want to do is make you
uncomfortable yeah that's great you're
comfortable with your language well i
know what part of the words were
that's all you need to do throw people
off what about extended family do you
have grandparents or anyone that's
that's over here
my dad should if my dad was like being
96 so
so no yeah how old was he when he had
you then
he was 45 when he was 45 okay a little
older yeah yeah he was 45
so me and my brother took after him
because i had my first kid at 40.
yeah and my second one at 49. 49's the
second one
yeah i do what i got to do how do your
knees feel how's your back and your
knees
um that's what always hurts well he's 48
i was 40 and a half going to be 49.
um no my my i do jiu jitsu so my back is
fine
knees are fine my feet hurt it's a
little weird but
it's my own issue so take me through
just now high school what is high school
like okay so
you know that's 1975 we go through
grade school i'm in catholic school for
nine years oh you are
senior senior kindergarten to eighth
grade damn they have a senior
kindergarten in canada they have junior
kindergarten
kindergarten two kindergarten years yeah
so it's basically uh what's the first
one you do here before kennedy
they call p pre-k or or yeah pre-k so
pre-k and
so you know same [ __ ] different name and
that you guys say eighth grade and we
say grade eight
it's the same okay same [ __ ] it's the
same way uh
lana's family the west indian indian
people will say
curry chicken and indians will say
chicken curry okay
yeah that's how we know the distinction
by the way they say like oh they're one
of those okay
oh you were there i got you okay
[Laughter]
chicken curry yeah hydrowal yeah
do you want curry chicken um
[ __ ] i know what you're doing um
and they're curry's a different color so
we're like that's who we need people
we're gonna go
wrong color i don't know what you've
done here but
um it tastes good anyway side note okay
so i get through
i get through nine years of catholic
school um
a lot of i deal with a lot of things
during that time
like what just a lot of racism and just
getting even from the priest and [ __ ]
like that did you ever get any of that
no but even at a young age and it was an
atheist because i would go to church and
i was like
this doesn't make sense thank you you
weren't allowed to ask questions and
that made me
even more i'm like well if i can't ask
questions then how to [ __ ] you
if you can't give me an answer you're
supposed to believe no [ __ ] i do
not yeah
i need and if god's everywhere why do i
got to be here son yeah why was god
needing my [ __ ] money
yeah yeah and why isn't god stopping you
from [ __ ] that kid over there
and that one and that one and that one
and i kind of felt bad because they
never [ __ ] me i was like
i was like undesirable i was a very cute
[ __ ] kid i don't know what their
problem was
they didn't want the brown one yeah they
wanted the brown stain just not the
brown kid
um this is one of my favorite memes if
you want to share that again
good things come in small packages oh my
god
oh [ __ ] i assume you've seen um
oh now i can't even think of the
documentary with the whole
the none the baltimore documentary i
can't i'm embarrassed i can't think of
it the
the nuns with the whole priest expose
the catholic church not just having sex
with boys but
what children there's so many girls what
the [ __ ] it called
uh the [ __ ] a boy documentary i don't
know it's not just boys that's a thing
oh wow they were [ __ ] girls they were
[ __ ] children yeah i know that's
weird
yes children i don't know why it didn't
matter what i don't understand that
[ __ ] obsession
as a father you know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you have kids
yeah i'm a six-year-old girl you get it
yeah i told you look when you go i got
it before i had a kid though yeah me too
i've always been into mature porn
women and uh
[Music]
it just came to me the keepers the
keepers okay just came to me where is it
netflix okay it's great and you
absolutely need to watch it
it's it is eye-opening and i know some
people in it
uh my mother's connecting some people in
it a friend of mine's mom went to that
school and knew this teacher so they
murdered this nun
because she was gonna out them and they
[ __ ] wiped her ass out and then they
start talking to all these people that
have
real evidence like the gravedigger that
had the priest come to him and say bury
my porn here well he dug it up for him
and it's just stacks and pictures of
kitties
yeah that's so much proof and they all
walked scot-free and
they show you how they just moved them
not across the country
like from this parish to this one five
blocks down the street
yeah so you know this this happened to
me last year um
uh it was the daddy-daughter dance in my
daughter's school
and so the fathers we take a bunch of
the fathers like 12 of us
will take our daughters to dinner on a
date you know so
and the daughters will sit at one table
the father's at another table
so i get i get there maybe about 15
minutes late which is my ammo
um and uh
there's one seat left at the table for
me right here and at the head of the
table is the priest from the school
oh no and i sit down and i go this is
going to be fun
and so we're having dinner and
and uh the guy sitting across from me
he's like a real kiss-ass guy
so he starts saying you know father i i
got away from the church but uh
when i started coming back around you
know i realized how much i'm like and
i'm like this [ __ ] right here
i'm just thinking i'm drinking too so
i'm like
i'm looking around i'm like you know
i'll bring the guy i'm saying there's a
[ __ ] right here and then
and then he's like you know and it was
you know that i remember when i was in
school the nuns were so mean and they
used to hit us and
and they were really mean and then and
then the priest goes
yeah the catholic church the church has
changed the church has changed a lot ago
yeah now they just [ __ ] kids
and the priest goes
[Laughter]
could you imagine being one of the good
catholic priests everywhere you go you
gotta hear him you ain't ever not gonna
hear him
and that priest recognized me obviously
but because
because about six months earlier i think
it was six months earlier maybe
six months to a year before that my
ex-wife wanted my daughter to get
baptized because she wasn't baptized
and i didn't want to go and she was like
you have to go they won't do it if your
father's not there i go what if the
father's [ __ ] dead what do you do
then dig one up like
no i don't want to go she's like you
have to come or the nugget i'm like
fine so i showed up in a wu-tang clan
sweatshirt and a baseball hat
yeah and uh i'm standing there like this
when the priest was like
and now you are and then jesus said i go
no he didn't
and he's like and everyone's looking at
me and then they go please make a cross
sign the cross on your daughter's head
so everyone my you know my ex-wife has
to do with her parents and then i
and i go yeah i just want this one
and the priest goes it goes like this
okay
like you know if you want to kick her
out of the school having a problem with
it
bro so yeah you know that's where i was
at anyway so eighth grade now you're
going to high school is this yeah
so eighth grade yeah yeah i i was
supposed to go catholics i didn't want
to
because i didn't want to wear a uniform
because i'd already started breakdancing
and i wanted to be cool
so cut this in 1984 now yeah i'm already
break dancing for about a year and a
half already what do you mean like on a
team or competing i was just dreaming
you know i was into hip-hop i was
already i'm a
boy i would walk to scoot my boom box
you would you carry the
[ __ ] day i would do it and i was a
little kid too i was listening to
grandmaster flashing the furious five on
that yeah
and then my brother would end up with
like these mixtapes and i'd play those
two
but anyway i'm playing all this [ __ ]
walking to school blasting it
and then i'd walk by the french teacher
and i'd play that part jump a pill
milly mill i don't want a lot of cheap
mademoiselles and i was like
[Laughter]
so you cut to uh 1984 summer uh you know
uh september 1984 you start i start
ninth grade
i'll show you what i look like um
i was born my birthday's in september so
i was already in school but
this is a picture from me on my birthday
in 1984 i'm turning 14. that's what i
look like at 14.
[Laughter]
1984 kids 1984.
i begged him dude you look like
[ __ ] out of t you look like uh
breaking you look like you had a break
that's her problem yeah i ended up i saw
breaking before i saw a beat street
and when i saw a beach try to go yo
that's the [ __ ] cool yeah but i
didn't know where to get that yeah yeah
yeah
so i was like mixing it with karate kid
and [ __ ]
break in and and i begged my dad for
that thriller jacket it was 99
and it was leather and it was [ __ ]
and ninety nine dollars and nineteen it
was a lot of
yeah i wore that jacket once or twice
got made fun of and never wore it again
and i to this day to this day
to this day um 37 years later i still
feel bad that i
wasting my dad's money on that [ __ ]
jacket and that's that's [ __ ]
guilt right there
because he didn't have a hundred dollars
it's a lot of [ __ ] money and he
bought it for me
and i didn't think he would buy it for
me i should have got the beaded jacket
now the beaded jack was a little too out
there but the thriller jacket
was way out there i had my it's so funny
you say that man
because i was not a fan of michael
jackson the
clothes awards i just wasn't i'm i don't
know maybe i was yeah but you're younger
than me i figured it you know but i just
knew that good was weird
okay chimpanzees and kids and [ __ ] and
i'm thinking about the catholic church
i'm like well how's this guy any
different
so my grandmother i'll never forget and
again she didn't have either but she
bought me this pair of black parachute
pants
oh yeah and i mean zippers all over them
oh yeah i had those that's what i'm
wearing in that picture actually i'm
wearing
black baggy pants with a zip down the
side with white mesh
or you can zip it down but i would
always have it down because i want you
to see my white mesh
i hung those [ __ ] up in the
closet and never
ever wore them and i still to this day i
feel bad about that
it was like that christmas present she
thought it was cool
she went out and got me these things and
i was like yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] i got my
chucks and my jeans i'm good
no i had my karate slippers on because
they were good for slime
ones the little black yeah with the
plastic sole yeah oh yeah cause they
were like five bucks
what was your like go-to move what was
the one with people you would do it and
people like oh i guess guy knows what
he's doing i used to do this one shuffle
um but i had to stop because my knee
started to swell up
because i was trying to this really fast
shuffle on the ground and i ended up
doing this thing where i
i kept turning like this and smashing my
knee but it looked really cool
but i'd go in a circle and then one day
my knee just was like this
and i was like i don't think i could do
that anymore and then i remember one
time doing a dive
into a worm or something yeah i was to
do a dive so i went and did the dive but
instead of sliding down like this i got
stuck and i scorpioned
oh my legs i thought i was going to
[ __ ] never walk again so
i saw you become a little bit more
cautious with my b-boy moves
and eventually i learned how to windmill
but it was too late then
that's some real [ __ ] the windmill
rolling on your shoulders like oh yeah
and i was doing seat belts and
and these and the seat belts and these
were easier to do than
actual keep doing it this way tell me
the truth when you're walking through
the house or whatever you're just by
yourself if you ever
bust out a pop and lock you still oh
yeah it's funny when uh
i have videos there's videos out there
of me like maybe a few months ago
um some kid was at my house and he said
he's a he's a b-boy and i go all right
so he did some [ __ ] and then i stood up
and i did my little
i top rocked and the top rock still
looks good so it looks like i'm about to
do something but i wasn't gonna
you're like i thought yeah i was like oh
she's gonna dive into a windmill i go
nah
i don't wanna do it right now because i
don't wanna [ __ ] break my hip my head
or my knee
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
now are you playing sports or anything
like that in high schools you see i was
a very small kid
i was feeling well you are small how
tall are you now 5 11. yeah you're
i'm about 215 two you don't yeah cecil
is gonna say i wondered if you are
always cause you got some size to you
and i would imagine people didn't wanna
[ __ ] with you then but you were a little
i was four foot eleven and i weighed 75
pounds in ninth grade yeah and i dressed
like that
yeah so understand what i'm working with
yeah and i'm already dealing with
being indian in 1984 and like nobody
wanted to talk
you're like how could i make this worse
i was trying to figure out how to get a
jerry curl i wanted a jared girl so bad
that's gonna be the photos all the black
dudes had jerry curls they're really
good ones
and they don't be like this go check it
out and they go like this they go like
this
we're gonna give you that just to see
their curls moving
that's how they knew they got a good one
they're like yeah it makes me laugh what
deod sanders always said looked wet but
it was dry
he said it all the time yeah yeah it was
uh so
well i was the old gangster look and
everything with uh nwa with the jerry
curry oh that was way too late that was
way too late this is 84.
it was pretty this pre in wa how pretty
though 80
it was about five four years yeah four
or five years before them 89 yeah
yeah so uh scary girl yeah so i go to
this you try to actually get one
no my mom wouldn't let me grow my hair i
did i'll tell you a funny story about
11th grade um anyway so ninth grade
and i'm getting picked on even worse now
in this school a lot of bullying
a lot of bullying and again race
relations related yeah yeah and then uh
and because i looked like that
and and i kind of had a slick tongue on
me too if you said something i was like
i'll say something
did you have a small crew at all that
also looked like that that you could at
least come back like man they're [ __ ]
no all my
all my friends went to the other schools
okay they were still at the
they went to them no no they just
wherever they went wherever else but i
didn't really
like there was jocks in this school
there was guys that played basketball
those guys that played football
and i so to this day i still [ __ ]
can't stand team sports
okay like what's your team i go to my
team is go [ __ ] yourself that's my team
you ever heard of them look at [ __ ]
yourselves speaking of teams i want to
say this real quick because this is just
a shout out to you and it's on my mind
i'm sorry it's just complete sidetrack
but
every time someone talks to me about you
and i talk to them
i talk about how you sold out the
raptors arena
seven times seven times and guess who
can't do that the raptors
back then they could not [ __ ] do that
now they can now they can but not back
then
no no that's [ __ ] beyond incredible
that's pretty cool
so good for you for [ __ ] doing
something a sports team couldn't look at
that
there you go and then they won the world
championship they did they they finally
got yeah finally i mean i'll i'll be
happy about that i'm happy about that
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor liquid iv
when we push our body hard or we're just
feeling run down it's extremely
important to take care of ourselves with
the proper vitamins
and nutrients that's why liquid iv
created hydration multiplier plus
immune support to maintain and
strengthen your immune system
i've told you guys throughout the entire
time i had covered and even still
i'm liquid iv in it all day long it has
vitamin c
vitamin d zinc it's so good for you
so good for your system hydration
multiplier plus immune support is a
cutting edge blend of vitamin c
zinc and wellmune and convenient single
serving packets to help strengthen your
immune system
zinc the second most abundant trace
mineral on your body supports immune
cell health
and function each packet is bursting
with fresh natural
tangerine flavor it tastes so good this
one's my favorite
liquid iv can provide two to three times
more hydration
than water alone it's the perfect
balance to help you strengthen your
immune system more quickly
and effectively and with every purchase
liquid iv donates a serving of liquid iv
to someone in need liquid iv has donated
four plus million
servings in response to coven 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military
get your liquid ivs hydration multiplier
plus immune support and bulk at costco
or order online
and get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use code honeydew at checkout that's
25
off of anything you order when you get
better hydration today
using promo code honeydew at liquid
iv.com
our next sponsor is keeps now the guys
here at the studio are using keeps
they're keeping that hair you know
they're young they're not like me with a
full head of beautiful hair they're
young and losing their hair already so
they're using this product
and keeps works man keeps offers a
simple stress-free way to
keep your hair two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time
they are 35 more than 50 million men in
the u.s suffer
from male pattern baldness convenient
virtual doctor consultation and
medications delivered straight to your
door
every three months so you don't have to
leave your home it's low cost the
treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month and keeps offers generic versions
they have discreet packaging and proven
results keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months
to see results so act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com that's
keps.com
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free
that's keeps.com honeydew k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash honeydew to get your first
month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com honeydew
now let's get back to the do anyway so
you know
this school ninth grade i'm getting
bullied a lot i'm getting picked on a
lot
dealing with a lot of racism uh i like
girls
girls don't like me but then when the
girls did like you
they had like because it was only white
girls they
wouldn't let you they wouldn't let
anybody know
so i used to walk home with this one
girl and we would hold hands and we
would make out and stuff
and then one day somebody saw her with
me i was like the [ __ ] you doing the
[ __ ] package she left on my hand i
was like i'm not with him
i don't even know him and i was like oh
[ __ ] and then that
really hurt me and then i like this
other girl and i wrote her like these
really
cute notes you know i think her name was
carla hill and i was like i would kill
for carla hill
and you know stuff like that and she was
really cute she was a
she was an elf in the mall and the santa
display and i mean i was like she was
really cute and then
uh and then she showed them to like
these [ __ ] [ __ ] guys they were
making fun of me
they were a great older than me and i
was like oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] all right
so i see so now i'm like getting all
this like oh i see what's going on here
and then i left school crying a lot in
ninth and tenth grade
so i never got good grades so in ninth
grade you're supposed to get
eight credits i got two
two and then i had to go to summer
school i took two classes i picked up
one you know what i mean
so i got three ended up with three and
then you're supposed to get another
eight in tenth grade then i got three
and one summer school picked up another
one got four so i had seven credits
at the end of 10th grade when you're
supposed to have 16.
and then the school was like you need to
get out of our school
really they kicked you out they they
sent me to the trade school down the
street because they were like you're
never going to graduate here
your marks are atrocious i got 13 in
typing
dude and none of them are talking to you
about what's going on with you there's
no
counselor that nobody [ __ ] cares you
gotta understand when when i
like when people talk about america in
the 40s and 50s and dealing with racism
i get it because there's nobody you can
talk to because the people you're gonna
talk to don't actually give a [ __ ]
because they no matter even if they're
not racist they still don't have any
empathy for you
right they're like so what are your
parents telling you when you go home
because i'm curious about
the parenting back then versus the [ __ ]
because i feel like we coddle our kids
a lot about you know hey this and then
so what do your parents tell you are
they my dad tough it up defend yourself
yeah tough it up yeah you know defend
yourself my dad is a was a little guy
and he had a bad temper
and he used to box in india so he was
like he would [ __ ]
your dad's box and your beat boxes yeah
yeah basically yeah
and he and he he would tell me like just
[ __ ] hit him
and i'm like i don't know how to hit him
my dad was like you need to learn how to
fight
so right before when i changed schools
the school i was going to was like a
tough school
like a lot of tough kids a lot of badass
kids went there
um and my dad was like if you're going
to that school you might want to learn
how to fight
so this kid that i told you that oh yeah
okay this kid that i used to hang around
with was a
canadian champ boxer willie he was like
go to the gym with willy
i was like all right and i ended up
starting boxing and i [ __ ] loved it
and i was actually pretty decent at it
turns out i was like i didn't know i
didn't know how to
he goes you yeah of course you [ __ ]
do it my dad's just like course
i'm good at it if i'm good at it you're
my kid you're gonna be good at it
and because my brother was six years
older so you gotta understand
when i start i'm like 15 and a half 16
you know my brother's 21
or 22 he doesn't he's and my brother was
a big guy he used to
read all his bodybuilding books and
worked out and stuff so he was but it
was like the 80s workout where you
weren't like jacked you were like just
swollen yeah
but like creatine puffs yeah like just
kind of weird like chubby but with like
everything sitting in the right place
you didn't have like a jawline you're
still like yeah you know but like
you know big guy some people and you're
now 16 so how much have you grown are
you still
like no i had grown now so now i'm 147
pounds holy [ __ ] you put on a [ __ ]
doubled your weight
almost right yeah yeah so i i got i had
a growth spurt in like on
end of ninth grade beginning of 10th
grade growth spurt and uh but it didn't
make a difference because they're still
skinny
you know what i mean so um i start
boxing i get good at it
i go to the tough school no not one
[ __ ] problem in the top school
not one because the tough kids the
little gangsters in that school
they're not punks they're not bullies
the bullies were at the other school
they were being dicks and bullying
because they could
and what do you want to do if the kids
that the kids at your school would go
kick the [ __ ] out of those kids
they would never push them yeah they
would never come that that would never
come to this going to start a problem
because they would get their ass well
right
but my school was all the tough kids and
it was mostly jamaican kids and
and uh and like crazy ass white trash
kids you know what i mean
and and what sort of trades what are
they teaching i took chef training for
two years you
you did yeah so across wish i knew that
was i always
in my mind when they talked about
vo-tech it was always
i always they never said anything about
horticulture or ships oh we have
horticulture classes
cars and mechanics [ __ ] you know they
had all that there too they had auto
bodies they had a mechanic shop they had
a machine shop
they had that was in a different section
of the school right right next to the
chef training class was the bake shop
class
yeah and then across a hall from us was
the cosmetology class
where you learn about hair and makeup
and all that girl yeah and then and then
next door to them was the sewing class
and i used to hang out in the sewing
class all the time
because the teacher miss kelly uh rest
in peace passed away like a few few
months ago but she used to
she was cool as [ __ ] she would let me
hang out in there because she was like a
hippie
and she had um she had married a black
guy in like the 60s
so she was like hip his [ __ ] she was
like i don't can she would swear i don't
give a [ __ ] you want to hang out here go
ahead hang out here
because you're not going to be a chef
anyway she's like i know there's
something better for you russell i know
she was one of those people who believed
in me i was going to ask you if you had
someone
she was that she was that one she was
the one she would let me hang out and
there was lots of
all the hot chicks i'm not hot chicks
but the the cool girls were in that
class and i was like there was some cute
ones in there i was like all right
i gotta hang around these chicks and
they and this is a different school this
is a different
a different way of approaching things so
these these girls are being nice to me
now
and you're not the [ __ ] kid no more
you're just another guy in the school
you're like wow this is great so
i go there i take chef training me and
my chef training teacher to this day are
still friends
he's really still emails me calls me
mr caller good guy he ended up [ __ ]
[ __ ] one of the students and marrying
her later on
no sorry freddie
um he did he was [ __ ] one of the
students he ended up marrying her
and then she you know jacked him and
took him for a [ __ ] but whatever i mean
you know jacked him and took a fresh
[ __ ]
oh my
and then that school it was funny
because the kids were like so
there you couldn't play with those kids
like i'd never seen that in the other
school because i
i i mean by that like you like around
them yeah no like
i could but like when the teachers like
in the other school be like
it'd be like you know like ryan go to
the office i'm like sorry sir i'm going
the office
and this could be like go to the office
go [ __ ] yourself you know like that's
what it was like in my school right
and it was like the teacher was like
breaking up a fight and then uh
and then the girls would turn on the
teacher don't [ __ ] touch me and then
start slugging on the teach and i'm like
yo what the [ __ ] so i got to see him
like i was like oh this is a different
that changed my whole thing i was like
oh i don't have to get bullied these
aren't [ __ ] bullies this is what this
is what real tough people do and so
it changed me all together there i
remember this one fight this guy
this guy eddie got into a fight with
this uh italian guy named
massimo and eddie had like a white you
know
everybody used to carry a rag in their
pocket back then he had a towel in his
pocket
so they start fighting and then eddie
takes a towel out of his pocket
throws it up in the air goes and then
massimo looks good
[Laughter]
that's old that's our old snowball fight
you throw one up somebody looks like he
goes
break the [ __ ] mouth yeah and i was i
remember laughing so hard that [ __ ]
day too
that's a great one yeah yeah so i never
got beat up ever again after that when i
changed schools
isn't that interesting yeah it is i
started boxing maybe that's why
yeah but have you ever been in a fight
oh yeah yeah a lot of fights after that
yeah once i learned how to fight i was
like oh i'm going to do this
yeah so i got into i used to i wouldn't
instigate them but if something popped
off i'd be like
let's go i mean what's it like look i've
been in a shitload of fights and i know
what it's like for a person to want to
take me off the face of this earth it
was a stranger's never met me doesn't
know a damn thing about me
but what is that like for
to face because of just the color of
your skin i
i'm sure i did something or whatever to
them it wasn't because i'm white
so what is that like to have to [ __ ]
literally fight for your life
well you're not fighting for your life i
already know how to fight so they would
talk slick and i'd knock them out it was
literally one punch
always one point oh you would cry it was
like pop
that's it all right and i wasn't like a
stomp you and beating i was like eh he's
already asleep [ __ ] am i gonna do with
that
so it was always it was almost very
quick so it never had a problem with
that it was never like
got into a knockdown drag out nobody
knew how to fight
you realize that once you learn how to
fight is that you go nobody knows how to
[ __ ] fight that's right
except today you never know mma
[ __ ] will snap their neck off
i do jiu jitsu now so now i'm always
like and jiu jitsu guys there's like
this brotherhood in jiu jitsu when you
see somebody
jiu jitsu you could be the guy that
hates your guts okay oh yeah okay
okay cool what's up bro you know it's
like this whole thing that changes you
know
it's quite a lovely thing it sounds like
it but anyway
so i graduate i end up becoming
president of that high school in 12th
grade what do you mean
you ran i ran for classical one
president you did yeah how hard
how hard was that the only one to make a
[ __ ] sentence everybody was dumb as
[ __ ] in that school if everybody
hated you not on the second school oh
the second second school you were
popular okay
i became popular because i was djing and
stuff then too already
where were you djing i started djing in
85. um
damn that is early you were your records
huh oh yeah oh yeah my first two
doubles that i intentionally bought were
the show dougie freshens liquid yeah
so i bought about two of those because i
intentionally bought it so i could
scratch
get fresh crew and then my first two
turntables were these techniques slb
200s they were belt drives so
and the pitch was a wheel there was no
like up and down pitch there was a wheel
so
yeah if you wanted to pitch up the
record you had to push do with your
finger
and then they would do it at this
ungodly speed
so you had to learn how to do it with
your fingers so you could just mix that
way
but then when you did do that you'd
stretch the belt don't fall off the
turntable return table would die
and then you'd have and then i'd go to
pick up my mom from work with my dad
just seemingly like i want to go for the
drive but i would go to the where they
sold turntables
lift off the platter steal the [ __ ]
room belt and put the platter back
that down um so that made you a cool kid
pretty much
yeah because now i knew music and i had
the new music and i knew how to get
music and i became that guy and i would
so
i i started having an identity now okay
i was the hip hop kid i play i dj'd i
used to break dance
i liked tagging a little bit you know
what i mean so uh
and these tough kids in that school were
all all about it they were like they had
no problem with me
because they were like man he's not
[ __ ] with us when i thought you know
he's
he's cool he's always says hi you know
because he's going to whatever but did
you run with any crews or were you sort
of your own guy
i was kind of my own guy i had like my
best friend marlon that i grew up with
stacco the big black wacko
um and so i was actually facetiming with
him when i pulled in as a matter of fact
we've been best friends for 43 years i
love that i'm still
really tight with guys from like sixth
grade seventh grade
43 years of best friends there so uh
he's a black dude jamaican as well and
then
everybody i knew was black after that it
was just like it was just so much easier
i never had any problems with them you
know what i mean so i was like oh this
is way better
there's so many it's so so so no
problems here this is the best way to be
so right
um i graduated in 88 i was class
president
um i remember there was somebody running
for office in my
town and their name was like something
like i was like ken russell or something
and i stole his signs and blacked out
the ken part and put the russell
i put russell all over the school vote
for rough yeah
and then i don't know which which i
heard some political candidates say this
on the news so
when we had to go from class to class to
pitch ourselves to the students i was
like
vote for me if i win you win
[Music]
that's it thank you and then the other
one's like
you know they couldn't form a sentence
and if i win i'm going to i'm like
yeah i'm gonna do [ __ ] and then uh i
came up like these designs for
the new school t-shirts and i had it
done graffiti style so because you know
i was a hip-hop minded kind of kid so
it looked pretty cool um anyway that's
high school and then i graduate and then
uh i don't go to college no no from so
from the high school
i graduated from you weren't eligible to
go to college
no because uh back your tech your
texts don't count no so in canada they
had a system
back then it was there was three one
four one and five one three one is basic
level education
four one is general and five one is
advanced
and i uh the school i went to offered
nothing but basic
and you weren't two one three yeah
pretty much
and i'm no joke one of the [ __ ]
english problems
in uh 11th or 12th grade was unscramble
the words and use them in a sentence
and one of the words was ferrari and i
go miss this is uh i own three of these
no i said this isn't a word it's a name
and i got kicked out for
challenging everything all the time
[Laughter]
but you are right yeah it's not a word
yeah i mean i was so scared of my
parents i remember i got in one
some trouble with one of the teachers
and i got sent to the office and the
principal was gonna
um call my parents and then i got so
[ __ ] freaked out but i was like
and i was like you haven't know what
it's [ __ ] like in my house all right
[ __ ] i was
getting freaking out to go and he was a
big older white man i go
why don't you do this why don't you come
to the boxing gym with me we'll spar
three rounds if you beat me up you can
call my [ __ ] parents
and i'm like come on [ __ ] let's
go i'll [ __ ] fight you to stop you
from calling my parents he was like
this kid's he crazy up letting me do an
in-school suspension because he was
going to suspend me for a couple of days
so what do you do after high school um
i get this job working with my cousin he
was a subcontractor for like the gas
company and we had to go house to house
and put these rain
shields on gas meters okay so i
literally walked around
and just put that plastic because
plastic cover on these brain shields
on on gas meters for the whole summer of
88
and then i got a job in a warehouse
after that because that's what my life
was doing i was like
and at this point there's no comedy in
your life or anything comedy starts a
year later
okay but what's the what what's your
influence i know you at this point i'm
sure you're watching comedies you have
some favorites
understand 88 you're still not really
watching it you're listening to it true
so i'm listening to records i had all
these carlin records but no snl or
anything like that i didn't really care
about it you know what i mean it was you
had to be home to watch that on a
saturday night and i'm
18 years old i'm trying to go to the
clubs i'm going all these all ages clubs
start going all the way just
15. oh really up there's that early yeah
15 all ages clubs you can go there
no there's no alcohol no [ __ ] okay club
404
you know we'd go there club 404. it was
a fun times
uh then there was all these like other
little all-ages clubs and then
you know uh the nightclubs in toronto
they used to serve alcohol until one
back in the 80s and then after one they
would open it up to all ages
oh okay so you go to like a nightclub
there's this after hours club called
twilight zone that everybody used to go
to
and uh it was in downtown toronto and
they used to just play house music
and this is when house music was
underground still so i would go there
all the time i remember going there in
85 i was 15 and
i would go after one and i remember
falling asleep in the club because i
couldn't stay up there
and because it would be housed and i
fell asleep sitting there and then
they put on whoppit by b fats remember
it was a whop it it was a song but be
fats whop it i remember sleeping and
then i heard whopping i go and i got up
and started doing the whop
and then i went back to sleep
and um and also back then i would see
lennox lewis because i was boxing
amateur and i i would go to the
tournaments
now let me just clear something up
because i never actually had any fights
i would go to the gym fight spar with
guys get ready for fights get guys ready
for fights
and then my coach would be like we were
i got you a fight in two weeks i'm like
and i wouldn't show up for three weeks
because i was like i don't want to fight
i just wanted to train learn how to
fight and i didn't mind like getting
into a scrap
like you and i know each other we're
sparring i'm good with that and you want
to beat [ __ ] out of me that's fine too
you ever get knocked out like that
uh i got uh i've been knocked down a
couple of times
not out cold but definitely knocked down
one what's it like um
slowly do this you have that head gear
on do you have it
like just and then like you hear you can
slowly hear the
sound yeah going away fading out yeah
that's that's what it's like
it's like being a vacuum and you're just
done
and uh oh body shots are worse and
[ __ ] worse yeah
i mean i've seen guys get it and they're
just they just go i
used to there was this guy larry in my
gym big jamaican guy
heavyweight and uh i started at 147. i
think i might have been 160 by this time
and his sparring didn't show up that day
so my coach was like russell go spot
with larry
larry's 220 225 maybe damn he's like six
three
i'm i think i'm 5 10 at the time five
nine five five nine probably five nine
five ten
um there you go russell sparrow there i
go
[ __ ] that i make too much fun to larry
every day
in the gym to get in the ring with this
guy because i make fun of him because he
was very jamaican and
awesome look homer oh i'm doing a boy
and i talked so much [ __ ] [ __ ] to me
and i'm like
i'd make fun of him like making fun of
his english or whatever but that's just
and
and he would he had this huge not the he
had a huge dick
and he would always walk around the
dressing room with his dick hanging on
i'm talking this motherfucker's [ __ ] was
this
those dudes and i'd be like hey like i
finished training
oh come in never shower i go cause i'll
shower at home i don't [ __ ] need you
to see my peanut with that
yeah that [ __ ] elephant trunk you
know peanut butter yeah yeah yeah he'll
be like yeah
yeah it's so yeah his dick could have
been his sparring party you know what i
mean like
yeah so i'd make fun of him all the time
anyway his sparring didn't show up to my
coaches like hey go spar with larry i go
[ __ ] that larry
no i'm not getting hit by a heavyweight
you crazy he goes he's not gonna hit you
he's gonna work on defense
and i go so i can hit him he's not gonna
hit me right
all right so i get in put my headgear on
mouthpiece everything
get in the ring ding ding i start
lighting them up cause i'm faster than
i'm like pop pop
pop pop pop pop pop pop and i start
talking [ __ ] hey larry you're really
[ __ ] slow
pop pop he's you know moving he's just
getting out of the way
he's not getting hurt by me and anything
but i'm i'm getting confident because
i'm hitting him lighting him up i'm
hitting his body
i'm getting this i'm getting his head
lightly you know what i mean i'm i'm
getting things on him and then i'm and i
start
i'm talking so much [ __ ] i gets to him
so i throw a jab
he dips pop right under hits me right in
the liver i'm like
i dropped and i made this noise
[Applause]
and my coach like get up i go [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you bro
you know guys like to fake and i always
go right there on them
because because i was going for the head
and i'm like pop do you know what you
know how [ __ ] sensitive that is yeah
it's the
yeah it's so oh god there and i give it
a light tap just to let you know
you're right open oh what the [ __ ] was
that like your body
you're gonna piss blood tomorrow but
you'll be fine after that oh yeah well
we just have
good times going to the tournaments
though because my coach understood after
a couple of times he set up fights and i
didn't go
he was all right this [ __ ] guy just
wants to train and uh so he would let me
do all that and then
we'd go to tournaments and i would see
lennox lewis because he was at a
different gym in a different city
and i just knew it was a tall skinny guy
which periodically see him
and then in 88 lenox won the gold gold
medal for the canada
in the olympics i remember being at
twilight zone
and i saw lennox he had just come back
from the olympics i was like congrats
landon he's like hey good to see you
thanks man and
subsequently him and i became very good
friends over the years that's great
um to this day we're still very close
and um
i'll show you something really cool that
he sent me in september
uh he was doing i don't know why i first
i don't know why he sent this to me he
sends me this video of him right
and he's talking about him and i growing
up together
and i'm like okay that's cool but why'd
you send me this [ __ ] video
so he's doing this video about talking
about people that grew up around him and
he's talking about
russell peters and and he's wearing the
suit and uh was
the famous russell peters and he's a
great comedian
my friend i used to buy mixed capes
i did i used to mix it
look at the inside of that suit oh [ __ ]
yeah
he's actually over my fireplace
the lining of the jacket is the picture
of me and him of you and him
that's fantastic so he didn't tell you
that it was something you saw
when he released it yeah no he sent it
to me that's that's that's
the picture in his suit wow that's
[ __ ] awesome
yeah so it's pretty wild that uh you
know
you grew up with these kinds of people
and then you think about the people that
grew up around i think about the people
that grew up in my neighborhood like
people go [ __ ] is brampton for i mean
like brampton came up with some we had
some good people come out of brampton
scott thompson from uh uh kids in the
hall
uh michael cera brampton um
the director little x okay he did all he
does all of drake's videos now but he
did like
all the cool videos in the 90s they did
like redman and he did sean paul videos
and he's done all kinds of great videos
you and lennox me and lennox damn
um there's a that kid uh
uh he's a rapper now tori torrey lanes
is from brampton
uh tristan thompson is from brampton uh
there's a lot of people from my city
and you'll notice most of them are black
like you said except for scott and
michael
okay so
comedy starts a year later for you
comedy starts a year later
um we were we were going to this
nightclub one time
this must have been this was in the
summer of 89.
i hadn't turned 19. you had to be 19 to
get in the club but i never usually got
carded
because i usually kind of knew somebody
um but we went to this club in brampton
and the
course they [ __ ] card and i couldn't
get in so
we're hanging out in the parking lot of
of this nightclub
and i stand on my friend's bumper of his
car and i start making fun of people
and they're like oh you need to do
stand-up you really then my cousin
andrew
i said something we were hanging we had
a family thing and i started making
jokes and because you know you're really
funny you should really go do stand up
and when my cousin said it to me rang
true because my cousin's never [ __ ]
paid me a compliment before
yeah then yeah he was like you could you
go to yuck yucks and do stand up and
like really
and then my parents started giving me
pressure what are you going to do with
your life what are you going to do with
your life you're 19 you're going to be
19. you don't have a [ __ ] career you
know
no job nothing and i'm like i don't know
my i told my brother my brother's like
what do you want to do
and you know my brother's 25 at the time
i'm like i don't know everybody told me
i should do stand-up because
once you try stand up then have you ever
seen it live i go
i have never seen it live so he took me
to like a couple amateur nights to go
watch
and when you watch when you're if you've
only listened or
watched professionals it's intimidating
but if you go and watch amateurs you're
like i'm better than that [ __ ] guy
yes and that's how i gauged it so i
started
watching live shows in september of 89
about a month and a half after i turned
19 i went and did it
and then here we are 32 years later dude
you're
[ __ ] just i mean
it's funny to me sometimes and this is
no disrespect
i say russell peters and people like
russell peters and i'm like oh he's
one of the top three [ __ ] earners on
the forbes list for comedy in the world
and i'm they're like
he sold out toronto raptors seven times
madison square garden
o2 arena tom opened for me there really
and that one yeah
and in 2010 when i shot my green card
tour special i took tom to england with
me to open for me
where is your favorite place to perform
um
or one of them let's not single anyone
out i don't know because i really have a
good time everywhere
yeah um auckland new zealand is usually
99 of the time the best show on every
tour
i don't know what it is about auckland
but the audience gets it and they laugh
with you on
every [ __ ] joke they're a good comedy
audience good great coming great comedy
i was just texting with uh israel at
asanya the other night uh
talking on dms and i said i'm coming to
nz next year and he's like
oh i'm coming i gotta be there for sure
and i was like that's pretty [ __ ]
cool
that is great all right so now that
we've talked about what we talked about
advice to your 16 year old self what are
you going back and telling russell
at 16. russell at 16 i'm gonna tell him
um work harder
that's interesting focus more uh
on what everything that you're doing
okay whatever you're doing focus more
pay attention more um
and don't harbor all that anger that
you had i had a lot of resentment
towards a lot of things when i was
growing up and i realized that you know
i went through i went through a phase
of uh of [ __ ] a lot of women doing
uh breaking a lot of women's hearts
doing dirty
and uh and i would tell them don't do
that in the future and pull out
pull out kid never trust a big butt in a
smile
truer words have never been so doubt
that girl is
poisoned yes and it's funny because i'll
always call them
i don't call them uh belle beverage i
just call them bell biv
because um my uh current lady used to
date ronnie definitely ah you gotta get
re we gotta drop the d
yeah the only d you're getting is mine
that's [ __ ] fantastic uh
thank you so much for coming on we got
to get you out of here thanks for making
me come
i mean wait a minute son of a please
promote everything again your podcast
your
your website for the tour dates podcast
culturally canceled with russell peters
on
iheartradio yeah you download it
wherever you get your uh uh
uh podcast from you know you know what's
funny is i've done a [ __ ] load of
podcasts in my life done yours segura's
joe's a bunch of times um is this your
first one
that you're doing yourself what i'm
doing myself oh it is yeah rogan told me
at the beginning
i was in i did his podcast in july and
he was like you need to do a podcast
i go to be a guest because yeah if i
could be a guest so
i think he kind of lit the fire
underneath me good
um and
i don't know i've done so many i've
never actually listened to one
isn't that funny i've never listened to
a podcast in my life i go to youtube and
watch clips of people's podcasts but
i've never actually sat and listened to
one
it doesn't matter anyway do what you
want to do with it that's the beauty of
podcasting yeah
don't take anyone's [ __ ] notes yeah
and do exactly what you think is the
best
it's exactly what mine is mine is just
hanging out listen to me this
right here and i know you and i are on
different [ __ ] levels but i will tell
you
i don't look at anybody as a different
well i do because i'm looking up
[ __ ]
and this may be the only thing we get to
do in our careers that doesn't have
someone weighing in somehow on it this
is pretty sure there will be eventually
depending on who who distributes yours
i'm solo i'm not with the network but it
doesn't that's probably the way to do it
well look but look at this you're solo
and you have a studio
with logos and signs and pictures
i'm in my backyard but you can be right
look time
mine is only audio well you gotta have
video bro i know it'll set you up you
gotta have i need to do that i need to
get better on that
all right well tom's the guy tom segura
is the guy that brought me into ymh
and then sent me out and you know i
i say all the time you don't get the
opportunity from a comedian and a friend
like tom and then throw up a shower
curtain behind you so
i mean but you have the opportunity
that's your podcast
hey god that's caught there bro thank
you all uh
as always for your support uh make sure
you sign up on that youtube channel
as always we have a patreon channel i do
have a patreon it's called the honeydew
with y'all that's why i was nice and his
only fans is coming up guys
i will have an only fans eventually yeah
because the older it gets the biggers
balls get they will look like honeydews
[Laughter]
uh as always ryan sickle on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all
next week
[Music]
you